welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar the role of Limbs
and achieving ISO 17025 compliance and
cannabis testing laboratories presented
by Arun optech CEO of cloud limbs my
name is xavier guitars and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring in this educational
web seminar presented by libraries
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Arun op day I will
now turn the presentation over to him
Thank You Xavier for the introduction so
today I'm going to be talking about the
role of limbs in achieving ISO 17025
compliance in cannabis testing labs so
first why achieve ISO 17025 there are a
number of reasons for achieving the
accreditation in many states such as
California it's a legal requirement but
for other states it is still desirable
because it communicates to the growers
or potential customers that you take
quality seriously then we'll talk about
the latest changes to ISO 17025 in 2017
a new edition of the standards came out
and so anyone who's becoming compliant
today would be using the new standards
then we'll talk about the two major
areas of requirements the management
requirements and the technical
requirements and
a Lim's can help with each of these two
major sets of requirements and finally
there'll be an email Q&A you can email
in your questions and we'll respond
so why achieve ISO 17025 what do you
gain from it
ISO 1785 is the internationally
recognised standard with this standard
you were communicating to all of your
potential customers that you take
quality seriously it provides a
framework for you to have continuous
improvement and self correction in all
of your laboratory results it also has a
number of legal ramifications by
improving your defense ability in case
of any type of regulatory or legal
questioning of the laboratory results
you will be able to provide all the
necessary documentation that your
instruments are calibrated that the
people running the tests will probably
were properly certified to run the tests
everything that you need for a court or
auditory defense and it reduces your
total cost of doing business
because the number of retest you need to
do when you're following these quality
standards is greatly reduced so let's
talk in more detail about why you would
want to get accredited by getting
accredited you gain recognition by
following this international standard
that you are technically competent it
shows that you have a sound quality
assurance system in place you gain the
cost savings from not needing to do the
retest you get increased business
because your customers will see that you
have demonstrated your commitment to
quality and it allows a systematic
approach to all of your quality
processes which actually results in
higher throughput which further reduces
your costs how does this benefit your
customers well your customers have
assurance that they are choosing a
technically competent laboratory that
you have done everything necessary to
ensure that the quality of the testing
results which our laboratory issues are
to the highest standards possible your
customers then have more confidence in
your testing
results and a higher satisfaction level
ISO has been updated in 2017 a new set
of 17025 standards came up they
introduced a new chapter on risk-based
thinking they introduced a more general
flexible framework for non conforming
tests and calibration work all the
terminology has been updated for example
the definition of a laboratory was added
there are references to the controls and
data information management basically
they're talking about limbs the
standards body recognized that the
majority of laboratories by this point
I'd switched from using manual
paper-based systems to using electronic
systems and the scope has been expanded
to cover all laboratory activities let's
take a look at a typical cannabis
testing workflow in a typical workflow
the client a grower or a manufacturer
would go into your client portal and
request a sample test the samples are
then sent to the laboratory bar-coded
and accession tests are then conducted
the results of the tests are recorded it
is generally then bumped up from the lab
technician who conducted the test to the
laboratory manager who then validates
the results and certifies that the
results are correct this enables the
next step of issuing the certificate of
analysis which is usually done through
the client portal and emailed as well
the client is invoiced and the samples
are disposed of in each one of these
steps in a cannabis workflow there are
ISO 17025 requirements and there are
ways in which a Lim's can help you what
are the major challenges faced by
cannabis labs in achieving ISO 17025
well there are a large number of
requirements it's actually quite a thick
documentation when you look at the
standards and it requires a thorough
evaluation in addition you have to do in
lot of training steps for all
the staff within your laboratory
everyone from the upper management down
to the individual laboratory technicians
and you'll want to set up internal
audits to prepare so by the time you go
to the third-party assessment you have
already internally certified that you're
following all of the standards so now
we're going to go into these specific
requirements there are two sets of
requirements in ISO 17025 there are the
management requirements and the
technical requirements for the
management requirements there is the
organizational structure which is
basically both your management hierarchy
and which of the individual staff people
are authorized to do what operations
within a laboratory document control
this ensures that you always have your
latest operating manuals SOPs all of
your documents are both the latest
version and the track to the individual
tasks you review of request tenders and
contracts
if a client puts in a request for a
particular task the first step is you
need to certify that you have the
capabilities of conducting that
particular tasks maybe your technician
who is the only one who is certified for
that test is on vacation or sick you
would need to instruct the client that
you are no longer able to do the tests
or that they'll be a delay because you
need to wait for your technician to come
back control of Records
these test results are all confidential
so you need to ensure that only the
correct people have access to the
records and that eventually the records
are disposed of purchasing service and
supplies
the quality of the service and supplies
that you purchased can directly affect
the testing results so if you have an
SOP where you're performing a test and
you switch a reagent from vendor a to
vendor B maybe vendor B has a cheaper on
the supply when you do that you then
need to recertify your tests and update
your SOP that this is now an authorized
vendor and you have conduct
did a control experiment we're used to
supply from the new vendor and have now
authorized the use of this vendor as one
of your standard suppliers internal
audits you need to periodically conduct
internal audits to test all of the above
so basically each one of your above
procedures you'll want to routinely do
internal audits and then track all of
those results so now we'll go into
detail for each one of these management
requirements the organizational
structure each laboratory is required to
have a well-defined organizational
structure you need to have define the
responsibilities of each one of your
laboratory personnel which includes
which tests are trained on which ones
they aren't and for all your key
personnel a good good limbs a modern
limbs can do all of this for you so here
you can see we have a number of
different technicians and we can control
what they have access to do they have
access to the clients do they have
access to the test results
it also will enable you to set the
permission levels for multiple testing
facilities so one of the trends going on
right now in the cannabis industry is
many of the cannabis testing corporates
actually own multiple labs one in each
state or multiple in each state so using
a modern Lim's like this from a central
location you're actually able to set up
the organizational structure across
multiple lab locations document control
all of the documents used including your
SOPs your manuals your testing
procedures need to be created approved
and issued and anytime there's an update
they need to follow the same review
process so your limbs should have a
document module here you can see in this
limbs there is a document module that
shows the SOP the forms and the latest
version so by doing this you ensure that
you always have the latest version as
one being followed and you can actually
track the particular SOP that was used
for a test all the way back review of
request tenders and contracts as we
discussed before any time a request
comes in the laboratory manager
generally is the one that needs to
certify that the lab currently has a
capability of the executing that
particular test if it's a new type of
test that the laboratory hasn't done
before then the client needs to be
informed that we are not yet certified
and I'm not set up to this lab or if
there's a temporary problem due to
instrument malfunctions the
unavailability of reagents personnel
then the client needs to be informed we
cannot do this test or we can do this
test but there's going to be a delay a
Lim's can handle all of this so here you
can see a client request that has come
in so the client has gone to the portal
and made a request the laboratory
director is unable to review that
request and send back to the client yes
we can execute this and if they want
they can even include a timeline you'll
be getting your results right our
average turnaround time at this
particular point in time these two days
so in two days you can expect to be able
to log into the client portal and see
your results control of Records
another important management requirement
in the standards is a control of all all
records so this means that when you have
conducted the test for a particular
client only that client and only the
people in that client organization we're
authorized should be able to see the
results and within your own organization
only particular people should have
access for looking at the records
indexing them and you need to have your
storage requirements how long do you
keep the records you keep them for five
years ten years
it varies state to state how long you
should keep the records although
nowadays generally with limbs because
you're so little cost involved in
keeping the records most people keep the
records indefinitely how can the limbs
help with this well here you can see all
of the test results that it
stored within the limbs each one of them
in the organizational level you were
able to set who has access to that
particular test records here you also
have the ability to go back and based on
time if you were to stop having a
particular client you could then remove
the records based on a particular client
or based on the time line in order to
keep your database from going oversize
as well as to prevent any other access
to data that you no longer want to have
be accessible
purchasing service and supplies all of
these services and supplies within a
laboratory can affect the test results
so as we discuss if you have performed a
particular task using a reagent from
vendor a and you want to switch to then
Derby first you would want to conduct a
control experiment using the reagents
from vendor B and then set them up as an
authorized vendor a modern Linz can
track all of that so here you can see we
have the particular reagent
we're tracking its expiration it will
set an alert to any time that the
reagent is expired and set an automatic
reorder a certain number of days before
the reagent would expire and it has the
vendors you have a list of authorized
vendor with the specific reagents that
are authorized for each vendor so this
allows you complete control of the
inventory management to ensure that all
of the inventory that you have available
has all been tested through controls to
ensure that those reagents will work
internal audits all of the above
procedures you want to review through
internal audits you can conduct the
internal audits with whatever timeline
and scope you want meaning you can do an
internal audit that covers a whole
laboratory or you can look at a specific
aspect for example document management
within a particular internal audit and
all the results from these internal
audits should be trapped you can see the
tracking here
contained within the lens so each one of
the audits is here this particular one
is showing the vendor supply audit you
can make sure that all of the tests that
are being done are performed with
reagents that have been through a
control experiment so now we've talked
about all of the management requirements
and how a Linz can help you meet the ISO
17025 management requirements now let's
talk about the technical requirements
the technical requirements are about the
competence of your staff the maintenance
of all of your equipment your
measurements traceability so that
anytime you are conducting a particular
task you can trace it back to a control
test that was done the calibration of
all of your equipment the methods of
reporting the results and your methods
for ensuring the quality of your tests
and calibration results so we'll start
with the personnel only trained
competent personnel should be performing
either your test or calibrations and is
the responsibility of the management to
set up the training procedures define
the tasks and job descriptions and
formalize which personnel are authorized
to do which aspects of the testing job
so here we can see a number of
technicians have been set up and you can
see there are attended certified and
competent columns which allow you to set
whether for a particular tasks that
particular technician is authorized to
perform the test this also enables you
to do reverse traceback
so that if a particular test produces
non-conforming results you can see both
the technicians that were involved the
instruments that were involved in the
Regents were involved so that you can
then see what was the source of the
non-conforming result test and
calibration methods all of your
equipment needs to be periodically
tested and calibrated as per the
manufacturer's instructions a Lim's will
trap all of this so here you can see we
have the particular calibration results
it shows
what calibration was done when it needs
to be done again and it maintains all of
the SOPs that are the current updated
SOPs because instrument meant extra
factors will periodically issue updates
to their recommended procedures so this
is allows you to keep all the documents
for each one and show for a particular
test which version of the SOP was
followed for that test equipment all of
your equipment needs to be maintained it
needs to be periodically tested and
calibrated here we have the dates of the
last calibration we have the schedule
for the next calibration the limbs will
automatically give you a reminder when
the next calibration is due or the next
maintenance is due so all of your
maintenance and calibration is done as
per the manufacturer guidelines
measurements traceability each one of
your tests which are the live test
results that you're going to be giving
to your clients need to be able to be
traced back to the last calibration and
control study that was done to show that
your results are accurate this allows
for comparability of the test and
calibration results here you can see we
can take any particular tasks and trace
it back to the calibration that was done
on the same instrument using the same
SOP and the same reagents so that we
know that we're getting accurate test
results this is also very useful in your
defense ability so if any testing result
is a question you can show but we did
the same test using the same calibration
on the same instrument with the same
control and based on the control we are
getting the correct results the
reporting of results after you've
executed and decided to release
generally by the laboratory manager the
results you want to make it available to
the client so here we can see within the
limbs the test results in a format that
would be viewed by the laboratory
director we
then view the laboratory results and
decide to release them when they're
released the client it's usually done in
the form of a certificate of analysis so
this certificate of analysis is in a
format that's readable to the customer
the grower or the edible manufacturer
and is also available within the client
portal the final technical requirement
is ensuring the quality of the test and
calibration results you want to ensure
the quality of the results on an ongoing
basis by doing periodic control sample
tests or even better by participating in
a proficiency testing program such as
the emerald test they're a third-party
will provide a number of laboratories
unknown samples some may have been
spiked with pesticides some will have
different THC levels so by participating
in one of these programs you're able to
ensure your quality because you can show
that the results are matching with the
pre known controls or the pre known
unknown samples from the proficiency
testing program all of these quality
control samples can be shown within a
modern limp so here in our limbs cloud
limbs you can see we have all of the
control samples traceback
which is providing you with the
measurement traceability so what did we
learn we learned that you gain a number
of benefits by achieving ISO 17025
compliance it enhances your reputation
giving you a competitive advantage
because you have demonstrated to all of
your potential customers that you are
committed to quality and produce
defensible reproducible results that
there is a commitment within your
organization to follow operational
efficiency and management practices it
reduces your operational cost by create
by giving a system that allows you to
have higher laboratory throughput you
can do more tests in a given period of
time as well as reducing the need to do
any type of retesting because you will
have
you are non-conforming results and a
Lim's can help you with each one of
these steps by providing all of the
modules that you need for both the
management requirements and the
technical requirements so I hope this
has been educational and helped your
laboratory understand how a Lim's can
help you achieve 17025 compliance thank
you very much thank you everyone for
that informative presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2019
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon
goodbye